how's it going kiddo
it's jam sesh time yeah come on when jam
sesh time arrives we have to put aside
childish things like homework in med
school I have to close the shop I'm
sorry Frank I held off on raising the
rent as long as I could
made it's time my girl starts UCLA in
the fall you can't make your heart feel
like one just to finish it word I want
it that way they want what what way I'm
sorry are you bringing up the Backstreet
Boys it's actually a pretty good song
you don't always get to do what we love
though we need to love what we do
I never realized that was your secret
yeah since I was like 12 not a band I
like it
I don't want to be in a band and even if
I did I'm not gonna be in one with my
dad usually what is this new indie mix
on Spotify this is my band
guys this is my band this is my man I
say what do i do you know i mean we
could write another song this is so good
you wrote this yeah my dad Sam talks to
me no no like she's the adult it's just
her way of making it easier for you I'm
in these
maybe you could take a year off and
we'll see what happens are you
suggesting that I don't go to college
that I can stay and be in a band you
have the same thing that your mother had
and if she were here right now I've been
here my whole life I don't want
something to hurt you it's time to get
away
let's just do our thing what thing we've
never done this before do what we always
do just in front of some people
hey that's what bands tutoring
[Music]
[Music]